before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
dialects do not have managers
Eve of the dialects well flux really
needed a palette cleanser and this this
will do nicely I was a little nervous to
go back to that because I remember
really liking it I remember thinking
this is definitely why Chipmunks better
stories
and some of the stuff that I've
rewatched has not held up as well as I
would like and I've realized some of it
I was grading on a curve more than I
realized but
this is still good is it like absolute
top tier doctor
no
it's not but
huh it's fun it's inventive it's got a
neat Central conceit
I just have a good time with this it
just
sometimes an episode of Doctor Who is
like well that's just fun and in the
reality you mean that's
kind of silly but it just kind of
tickles me like
if we're gonna give Chipmunks some
credit I kind of have a soft spot for
um dinosaurs on a spaceship it's just
just fun
not a special deal but it's fun
this is fun but also like it's not only
fun yes it is absolutely fun but it's
also got some cleverness to it it's got
some good performances and it's got some
great moments in it and the core idea
just the nature of the time Loop is well
done Doctor Who has not done time Loops
nearly as often as you would think given
that time travel is so Central to the
show
but here we go I mean there have been a
couple here and there depending on how
you wanted to find a Time Loop Heaven
Sent would be the one most recent to
this and this doesn't even come close to
that but if that was using a Time Loop
to be introspective and philosophical
this is using a Time Loop to
just have fun and I'm gonna end up
saying fun and awful lot hope you didn't
make a drinking game out of it because
it's just a good word for this
I like just the closed in space like
we're not dealing with a large amount of
space they're stuck in just this
building and it's not that interesting a
building but we're stuck here we have
limited resources and we have dialects
to deal with additionally with the time
Loop I'll actually rather like the
notion that every time the loop happens
it gets a minute shorter
that
I've never encountered that anywhere
else
but I actually really love that idea
because that is a great way to bring in
some pressure and counteract the one
major deflating aspect that a Time Loop
can potentially have because you can use
time Loops to do any number of things
but there's something that kind of
inherently takes the stakes out of it
which is that once characters realize
they're in a Time Loop they basically
have an infinite number of tries to get
out of it figure out what's going on
whatever
but to have characters who become aware
of the time Loop relatively early but
also uh it's shorter every time that's a
neat way to still play around with a
Time Loop but also be like yeah you
don't get to just bang away at this
infinitely until something works you
better get off your butt and figure this
out
I like that
that's a really fun combination of
elements and it works quite well
I enjoy the dialects in this yes I know
everyone makes fun of the uh of the
character of Nick just ducking and two
Dalek shoot themselves
I know everyone makes fun of that and
I'm not gonna say it isn't a little dumb
but I think with the tone and the feel
of this
It just fits well and between the
dialects using far more rapid fire than
they normally do with the sort of
Gatling style gun and us not having at
least in my memory having ever seen
somebody do this before like don't ever
do it again
don't try and make me believe the dogs
ever fall for it again but under the
specific circumstances
yeah I'll buy it this time and I also
kind of like the show hangs a lampshade
on it lampshade hanging can be a
double-edged sword this acknowledgment
of yeah the thing we did is kind of is
kind of ridiculous like if you overdo it
it just you just sounds smug you just
come across or or even potentially lazy
like yeah we knew that was a problem but
we aren't going to fix it but this does
lampishing lampay lamp shade hanging
well I think there's a lot of strategic
analysis weapons assessment I'm about
already thinking did you joke
that was just the right way to handle
that situation as far as I am concerned
I like that speaking of the Daleks with
the Gatling guns like
it's just fun again
really sorry if you made a drink you
came out of that my use of that word but
I also can't see it without thinking of
this from I believe the channel is Joe
leaver I'll leave a link but here's a
clip and this time we have exchanged the
pew pew
and it cannot possibly Miss
I can't not think about that and and
that actually that didn't even like make
it like oh I can't take this seriously
anymore because this episode isn't
asking to be taken super seriously it
actually kind of makes it more fun any
honestly it kind of fits with moments
like when Dan just decides to mess with
the dialect to stall it for a bit and
he's treating it like it's an automated
function of this storage space he's like
I'm gonna report you to your manager
that I I think the the whole
thing fits with that
um would that feel but again that's also
just a great moment for Dan it's nice
it's one of the fun things about a time
Loop when a character becomes self-aware
and has that moment of realization of oh
okay so I can do something really stupid
and get a free pass on it because as a
way to distract the dialects like that's
real dumb but it'll work
because you don't have to survive the
distraction you're doing so yeah sure
have fun with it and I like that he just
like gets in close and just circles
around with it so he can't quite get his
gun in on it
tone of this thing it's just the feel of
this and I think it's great
there's some bits that are not as well
handled so I mentioned Nick already so
Nick is not as bad as I remember him
being oh actually let me back up Nick is
not bad as a performance the performance
is fine he's he's Charming he's lovely I
like him as a presence the issue is the
sort of specifics of the
characterization first of all
he's
let's go with neurodivergent coded
in terms of his behavior
and it really does it rides right on the
line between sort of depicting a
sympathetic view of this slightly off
behavior
um like I think the moment that
encapsulate that best is when Nick says
see you next year
have you been practicing that
yes
like that's a moment was like oh
he's trying
and honestly even the reason for saving
the stuff like the Monopoly board in his
storage unit
I kind of get that it's like it's not
mine I don't feel right throwing it out
but I don't want to look at it I'll keep
it here in case this girl I dated or
this person I went out with one time
ever wants it back
and as acknowledged by the end like
they're never going to come and get it
but like that's a thought process that I
I understand
but then we get the thing where he's
been coming specifically on New Year's
because he's certain that she'll be here
and he's been doing it for at least the
last three years
and that
that's sort of pushing it a little bit
I'm not going to say that's completely
out of the realm of possibility in terms
of certain behaviors for certain certain
types of neurodivergency but I am going
to say like it's being played for
uh creepy Factor there or at least it
comes across that way I think maybe they
thought it was endearing
um
they also have the woman like berate him
at one point like calling him
uh names and like kind of shouting at
him and I am thankfully like she does
get called out on that and it's a
heightened moment she's angry but like
even just that scene felt really
uncomfortable man you are weird
boss
that's the thing I'm not sure this
crosses over into flat out depicting
neurodivergent behaviors as creepy
but it's it's it comes uncomfortably
close it goes from me feeling like oh
they like this is empathetic and this is
kind of nice to be like
um I don't know about this and I I don't
feel comfortable saying it definitively
does cross the line but boy does it come
close it comes uncomfortably close to it
so
that's that's not great
there's also the stuff with Yaz and the
doctor and here's the thing the scene
between Dan and Yaz
is actually a pretty nice scene is it
that obvious
well maybe not to a good-hearted way
though
four years traveling the world with you
I saw it then I don't know why it's
where they put it in a in an episode
that is otherwise actually quite well
paced like we're in a situation where
things are not quite going to plan and
you're at a point where you need things
to go to plan and you're going to stop
and have this conversation now
like I'm not saying that I don't believe
the characters would do it I'm just
saying for the narrative flow
um I don't know about that the doctor
gets a couple of good moments I really
like her little speech something seems
impossible we try it doesn't work we try
again we learn we improve we fail again
I just like that and I also actually
kind of really love that in the loop
immediately after she gives the rousing
speech they get taken out almost
immediately
it's like it's making the point like
yeah that is what you're gonna have to
do it just because you had a rousing
speech last Loop doesn't mean you're
suddenly on top of this and you just get
wiped out like real early on and that
one like that's that's what I mean when
I say that this episode is actually
quite well structured and well paced
except for you know that conversation
between Dan and Yaz which is again a
decent conversation just like why there
um
but um
these things are
minor
ultimately
I don't like super love or need to see
either the two guest characters again
but they work for the story they both
bring in energy that is different from
the two companions or the doctors so
they do bring a contribution and neither
of them is so one-dimensional that I
can't stand them which has been an issue
with some of chibinals writing that's
not the case here and overall again
the way that is laid out the the pace
that it takes the tone that it takes it
feels like okay we just went through a
lot
let's just kick back be a little silly
but have a lot of fun and even things
like the escalation of what's his name
Jeff the guy who's not even there who's
using all these empty storage units in
ways that he's not supposed to be using
them and we just sort of find out more
and more and more and more including the
implication that maybe he lives there
though that one's a little bit of an odd
implication because largely he's been
treated as someone who takes needless
advantage and is a bit of a skeeze up to
that point but then when they get to
that one I'm like okay but does he live
there
because he's taking advantage or does he
live there because he doesn't have
another place to be
like again I'm not sure crosses an
uncomfortable line but it gets close it
at least glances in the direction of it
oh well
this one is all together
fun
it's just nice to have a chiminal
episode be fun
in terms of ones that he actually wrote
during his era I think this is the best
one
I do it's not the best uh episode of his
era overall ones that he didn't write
take that but for stuff he wrote this is
good
this is this is enjoyable this is Rolla
King this is something that I watched
with a smile on my face
and after the kind of faces I was making
at Timeless children and then flux
this is just nice
even the dialects what'd you think about
it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it patreon pays the bills
enables me to do this as my living even
if you can't help me out that way like
share subscribe they help
but um don't worry too much about it
what I really want you to remember is
that you are beautiful
you're valid
and you are loved
you are the council and I'm just running
the meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
and now my thanks my patreon supporters
to make this possible including Robin
Moore Zubin look fulla to rock the thing
that goes doink in the anime Ruth Oliver
B solitary pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters Jen t love
Auntie Kate 808 bernabi likes the poodle
Robin Powell Tracy scrabot angry Casper
Adam RDL Taylor Dave Hall Shayla gourlay
and Rosalind Bennett
you can get uh my the bat I get all the
names right and then I can't talk if you
want to hear me stumble over my tongue
after saying your name it's in the
rewards here on the patreon
[Music]
thank you